the potential cost of tests and
treatments for the corona virus could
cause some people to delay seeking
medical care and that could dent then
delay that delay rather could expose
others to the virus as part of our
series medical price roulette a
collaboration with clear health cost
we're taking a look at what some
Americans are paying our consumer
investigative correspondent that's Anna
Warner has been talking to people who
received big big bills it started to get
a fever just started to feel kind of
chills and I was just like oh crap you
know whatever they had I think I got it
Walking Dead actor Daniel Newman got
sick in early March worried he might
need to warn others if he were infected
he went to a Georgia Hospital where
doctors tested him for the virus but
then told him we are not allowed to
process the tests because there's a
really limited bandwidth of capacity on
how many tests can be processed per day
and so we are not allowed to send off
the test for anybody that has mild
symptoms he never did find out whether
the test was positive or not he says but
on the way out he asked was the cost
cover and they were like no you just
came into an emergency room it's gonna
be thousands of dollars the bill came to
over nine thousand dollars an amount he
says his insurance company is refusing
to pay yeah a lot of money yeah yeah and
that not even a personal level on a
humanitarian level that infuriates me
the fact that no one can afford this how
can a family of two or four kids afford
even one person at nine thousand dollars
much less for people on March 18th
Congress passed the families first
coronavirus response act under which
health insurers are required to waive
cost-sharing for coronavirus testing
several major insurers including United
Healthcare Cigna Humana and Aetna are
also waiving co-pays for coronavirus
treatment but it's not true of all
insurance plans doctor Tom Ingoldsby
heads the Johns Hopkins center for
health security we spoke with him before
the shelter-in-place orders if people
are scared that this won't be paid for
what happens if they don't get health
care if they don't get diagnosed for
most diseases this would be an
individual decision and people would be
taking risks into their own account but
here if people fail to get tested it's
basically at risk for everyone it's a
risk for society
do you worry most about the uninsured I
do I worry about the uninsured or the
underinsured those who have such high
deductibles that they won't kick in
until they've spent an enormous amount
of money trying to take care of
themselves the health insurance industry
is warning future insurance premiums
could spike and is now asking Congress
to set up a backstop contingency program
that if needed would cover a portion of
related costs over the next two years to
protect Americans from the consequences
of potential catastrophic costs I think
this whole corona virus has exposed the
holes in our health care system
representative jan Schakowsky told us of
her concerns in early March I think this
is going to make it worse
maybe at the in the long run because
it'll expose so many of the problems
maybe we can make some of the
corrections but we are dealing
immediately with a crisis that were not
really prepared for a 2019 census report
says some twenty seven point five
million Americans did not have health
insurance that's about eight point five
percent of the u.s. population by the
way we reached out to Daniel Newman's
insurance company about that nine
thousand dollar bill we didn't hear back
but we want to hear from you what are
your concerns about costs and your
insurance coverage are you losing your
insurance coverage email us at health
costs at CBS news.com again Gail that's
health costs at CBS news.com we really
do want to hear from people tell us your
stories Gail I'm hoping after they see
your piece and and you know they're
watching they're rethinking Daniels bill
I see why he's so upset because on a
humanitarian level you got to figure
something out certainly during these
times yeah he said he's not concerned
about himself he's concerned about
people who would get that bill and then
what do they do with it
people really yeah all right we're all
paying attention thank you Anna